[Musique]
une journée sportive a été organisée ce
mercredi 29 avril à l'espace réglé par
le département et le 2e langue de
figures emblématiques des sports de
combat étaient présentes séries et gaël
grimaud pour promouvoir à travers le
sport la santé et le bien-être et le
thème de cette journée assez faire
découvrir aux jeunes bat enfin déjà les
sports de combat bien l'art martiaux pas
les arts martiaux et aussi ma de ce
projet était un petit peu
sa voix
leurs limites
j'ai un petit peu leurs limites aller au
delà bühler gaël grimaud champion de mma
et parrain du chalenge thierry grimaud à
partager avec les jeunes son parcours
lors d'un débat intitulé vie tes rêves
ce ski ce que j'ai apporté c'est mon
espace de vie comment j'ai fait pour
devenir un champion et quelques est là
quand le cac l'était ben mon parcours
extérieur est ce que si ce que je devais
je jeu j'ai voulu apporter un beau jeune
qui soit
c'est leur donner un exemple est donné
vraiment l'esprit de
de la réussite de leurs projets des
jeunes qui ont pu découvrir des sports
encore inconnue pour une expérience
enrichissante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ce qui est le plus intéressant
aujourd'hui ça a été bien l'expérience
enrichissante et sur la part de
professionnels
la deuxième édition du challenge tirer
vraiment se déroulera ce samedi 29 avril
au dojo de champ fleuri
[Musique]